-Our next guest is
a television host
and number-one "New York Times"
best-selling author.
His latest book, "The Lightning
Rod," is available now.
Please welcome back to the show
Brad Meltzer, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back to the show!
-It is good to be back here.
We are back, right?
-We're back.
-We're wearing clothes.
-This sounds not too shabby
to be here with you.
-I didn't know if we were gonna
come out here
and there was gonna be
no one here. I had no idea.
And then, I heard screaming,
and I was like, "It's for me."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Everything else was just warming
up to this moment.
-My whole life, in fact,
right to here.
-This is fantastic.
This is a book that brings back
two of your beloved characters.
Is it exciting, one, for you
to revisit characters that
you obviously already have a
relationship with as an author?
And, two, it must be fun
to write a book that just
hits the ground running
like this one,
because it opens just with
fantastic action,
which I think people --
it's one of the things
they turn to you for.
-Well, what's fun is I always
start with my fears,
because what kind of neurotic
would I be if I didn't?
And so the scene opens up with
a character
who hands his car keys
to a valet.
And the valet takes
those car keys.
Instead of parking the car,
he grabs the steering wheel,
hits the little GPS button,
says the magic words "go home,"
and now the valet is
driving to the man's house.
He's got his car keys.
He's got his house keys
on there.
Because he's going to rob him.
This is a robbery.
And he gets to the man's house,
goes to break in.
There's another man
waiting for him with a gun.
And this isn't a robbery at all,
Seth.
This is a trap.
And the body turns up.
It comes to our hero Zig,
who's a mortician.
And from there,
he finds something on the body
no one else sees, and it leads
to one of the government's
most closely guarded secrets.
Now, I just ruined chapter 1 of
"The Lightning Rod."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's totally ruined.
-And it's only two chapters.
-That's the thing.
And then, in the end,
everyone's dead.
[ Laughter ]
So here we are.
-But it must be so fun to come
up with something like that,
that, I mean, is gripping
even to hear,
even more so to read.
As an author, do you feel that
click in your head
when you come up with an opening
sequence like that?
-Well, you know, my son,
for this book -- he never --
my kids don't care about
anything I do, but he's like,
"I'm reading this one."
And we're on vacation,
and he reads chapter 1.
And I'm terrified, right?
'Cause I've been reviewed in
all these different places.
They could say I'm good,
I'm bad, whatever.
But when your kid is
reading the book --
-Absolutely.
-And I'm sitting there,
and he looks up and he says,
"Dad, good opening."
And I'm just like, "I've done
it. I'm done, I'm finished."
So that's obviously fun,
but everything kind of becomes,
you know, part of what I use.
Like, today is
the 11th anniversary
since my dad died, right?
My character's a mortician.
So even at my mother's funeral,
all these things --
I just love that I brought
the room down
by mentioning dead parents.
[ Laughter ]
But even at my mother's funeral,
you know, they take us in.
It's this solemn moment
before everybody comes in
and we're there, and they say,
"We want you to be alone
with the casket
so you have a moment alone."
It's my sister. It's myself.
It's my dad.
It's my -- Two uncles are there.
No one else is there.
And they say to us, "You know,
if you want to say your
goodbyes, you can say them."
And my dad goes over to
the casket and he leans down
and kisses the casket over here.
And then the rabbi says,
"Actually, her head's
over here,"
and my uncle says, "Ha-ha,
you finally kissed her ass!"
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like,
"This is my family."
But that's what goes
in the book.
-It goes in the book.
-Everything's part of the books,
and the mortician and the death,
it all goes in.
-You don't just have, obviously,
life experiences.
You are known for
the level of research
you do for books like these.
And I know over the years,
you've gone in parts of
government buildings people
like us don't even know exist.
-Yeah, well, I've done
the secret tunnels
below the White House.
I've done the catacombs
below the Capitol,
and I love --
When I'm reading a thriller,
I love when I'm learning
something.
I love that detail.
So for this book, I found out --
And this is true.
The book's obviously fiction,
but I found out that
the government has a dozen
secret warehouses hidden
all across the country
to deal with
bioterrorist attacks.
So if anthrax or smallpox --
And the idea is that if there's
an attack in New York,
there's one in L.A.,
Texas, Idaho,
wherever it is, there's
a warehouse hidden by an airport
so that they can get an antidote
right to you
within a couple hours.
And I'm like, "You're telling me
the government has
secret warehouses nobody knows
about and no one can go inside?"
I'm like, "I gotta go inside."
So when you get to the final
chapters of "The Lightning Rod,"
you're not just -- It takes
place in these warehouses.
Everything you see in there,
I didn't make up.
It's all real.
They have cobra venom in there,
man.
I don't even know what they're
doing with cobra venom,
but they got cobra venom. I'm
like, "it's going in the book."
-Yeah. You have some wonderful
children's books as well
that I would like to talk about
real quick
because my kids are such
huge fans of them.
And these are books that sort of
talk about, you know,
historical figures,
inspiring figures,
and tell their stories
from when they were kids.
And you do it with a wonderful
illustrator, Chris Eliopoulos.
-Eliopoulos. Very happy.
-And how many of these have you
done, and what gave you guys
this idea to tell stories about
people like Martin Luther King
and Rosa Parks and
Neil Armstrong and Jim Henson?
-Yeah, so, you know, we started
this because we were tired of
our kids being fed garbage
on Instagram.
I mean, our kids scroll through
every day, and I was like,
"Let me give you better heroes
to look up to."
So we did "I Am Amelia Earhart"
and "I Am Abraham Lincoln."
Our newest ones are "I Am
Muhammad Ali" and "I Am Malala."
And what happened was is
I saw Muslims being picked on
and targeted even more so
than they have been
throughout history.
And I was like,
"I'm gonna do Muhammad Ali,
I'm gonna do Malala, and I'm
gonna make sure people learn
and show them
how to fight back."
Right?
And it was vital to do those.
-And they're really --
I should stress, you know,
they're beautifully written
books.
They don't shy away from issues,
but they're also incredibly
palatable, and I find it
a great way to introduce ideas
to my kids that way.
And some of them were taken off
bookshelves for a brief period.
-They were. It's great.
I mean, they literally banned
our books "I Am Rosa Parks" and
"I Am Martin Luther King Jr."
And I'm like -- They put me --
I got a call from Fox News,
from CNN, from MSNBC.
They all wanted to have me on.
They were like,
"This is a travesty."
When Fox News
and CNN and MSNBC agree,
you know you screwed up.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Right?
You know you went too far.
And we fought really hard
against the school board
in Pennsylvania.
The students in the area
and the activists in the area,
we spoke at the school board
meeting.
We got the ban overturned.
We told everyone, "If you want
to see this overturned,
you have to take the lessons of
Doctor King and Rosa Parks.
You must fight back."
And we did.
We got it overturned.
But it's happening --
[ Applause ]
I appreciate the applause.
I'll take it.
But the reality is, is
the reason we're seeing this
happening over
and over and over again --
You know, after it happened,
I went through history
and looked at what was
the first books that we banned
as a culture in the country.
And it was
Harriet Beecher Stowe's.
"Uncle Tom's Cabin,"
historians agree,
is the first one we banned.
And why?
Because slave owners
didn't want us
talking about how slavery
was bad for people.
They didn't want abolitionist
ideas to be out there.
And anytime you see a book
banned, it's because someone's
worried about losing their way
of life and their power.
And if you're cheering
while books are being
pulled off of library shelves,
you are on the wrong side
of history.
You're on the wrong side of
history.
So I love the fact that we've
been fighting back against it.
-I want to ask, because I think
there are gonna be --
For anyone who's approaching
the idea of wanting to be
a professional writer, you have
now written over 40 books,
you're a "New York Times"
number-one best seller.
You were rejected.
I think your first book,
I read somewhere,
was rejected 24 times
by different publishing houses.
What was it in you that made you
persevere that long?
-Listen, I was young and I was
stubborn, and I was like,
"If they don't like that book,
I'm gonna write another."
I mean, there were 24 rejection
letters.
There were only 22 publishers.
I got 24 rejection letters.
[ Laughter ]
Which means someone
was writing me twice
to make sure I got the point,
right?
But I said, "I'm gonna write
another book.
I'll write another.
I don't care."
But the truth is --
and this is my secret, right --
is that 23rd and 24th rejection,
when I got that call,
I thought they were gonna
be acceptance letters.
And I was in debt from college.
I was in debt from law school.
My agent said,
"Just wait by your phone.
I'm gonna call you, and I think
you're gonna be out."
I think I'm gonna get you
out of debt."
And I picked up the phone
all excited,
and I said, "What's the news?"
And she said, "Sorry, kiddo."
And my heart just sank.
And I will tell you, this is
the 25th anniversary of me
as a published writer, and every
single day I sit down to write,
I replay that scene.
I picture the phone
I was holding in my hand.
It was clear and see-through
with like --
You could see the wires.
That was like high-tech
at the time.
-That was the hip phone
back in the day.
-And then, I picture the Formica
desk on my left,
the swivel lamp
every college kid had.
I picture the bed
and the box spring on my right.
This little balcony in this
fire station with three doors.
I count them in my head,
one, two, three.
And then I say those words,
"Sorry, kiddo"
because I never, ever want to be
anything but thankful
for this life I have.
I never want to ever be
as hungry as I was
when I was 24 years old.
I never, ever want to not
appreciate, and I never want
to think I made it, because
if I think I made it, I'm done.
For 25 years, every single day
I sit down to write,
"Sorry, kiddo. Sorry, kiddo.
Sorry, kiddo."
It's just what I --
I need it to drive me.
-Well, it's fantastic that
it works as well as it does.
Thanks so much for being here,
Brad.
We really appreciate
all of your writing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The Lightning Rod,"
available now.